come what else
what else okay it played rugby seven is
an option
and queen f6 whoo that would be
that will be played that will be played
it's winning
yes oh b7 could have six this is
something it sees in no
no time yes yeah yeah yeah that's that's
that's it yeah that's it that's over
and yeah queen h8 is coming okay f1 it's
mate
it's mate it's over
okey two you just rule the queen okay
two three mate
check king f7 queen h7 and queen takes
b7
okay i will i will i cannot jinx it
here so i will congratulate maxime come
on on a
nice well played i might get on game it
was a tough match
but maximize another day
maxine leaves another day but he should
improve he lives
three other days four
three three i forget three close please
no sure 30 seconds for
finding an impossible solution doesn't
exist simply
black is it's over i think you will just
resign
20 seconds okay
yeah okay f1 is a killer very simple
maxim doesn't need
much time to to find is just
checking anyways you guys 20 seconds so
okay from g7 um
and quintex and two pawns
he's taking his time good
looks like there's nothing to get great
but okay
wow he doesn't do it that's amazing
actually
he's very tired by now not to see ok f1
immediately
is kind of okay this is also completely
winning of course
and rookie 7 also is
with check the check was very important
always made on e1
yes
and man and maximum is qualified for the
next